[Music]
actually this all has to stop do
something you've never done do someone
you've never done go someplace you've
never gone someplace that was scary I'm
always asking questions about myself
about my reality about my purpose
there's never a point where I won't have
questions about things as part of what
makes this life experience so beautiful
but the question sometimes are more
important than the answers so I keep
asking I looked into the mirror and I
confronted what I saw accepting the
reflection by embracing everything
directing the connection into breaking
down the walls by reflecting the
perfection of God and Silas all Hamish
he waited through a dream with a
kombucha solenoids uses community is as
important as installation we are here to
change the world I want people to
question their reality and to inspire
individual on social and political
change
the highest level from my art and to my
life and I really do think that's what
humanity needs more of right now is
empathy you know is people listening to
other people's stories and then telling
their own and being vulnerable from a
place of strength and I'm taking my own
medicine too it's not like I think that
other people need to do this I'm doing
it that's why I'm riding I want to
disappear when I'm onstage I actually
think that my personality gets in the
way I literally would love to be able to
get on stage and just be and that that
would be the best poem I've ever written
[Music]
I'm gonna do a few poems for you guys
it's a real pleasure that I was invited
here tonight life is all about you and
not at all about you now that's two
opposing thoughts and yet both of them
are true how can we experience
everything we choose to do while
observing the experience were having
from a higher view awareness but of Who
I am the journey that I'm getting to
gratitude is my destination my destiny
is perfectly aligned with this location
I am the map so my rhymes are like road
signs
I have everything I want cuz my
imaginations mine but mine is not enough
for me because I am NOT my mind I could
see it all and never get to see I'm
truly blind I could be it all but all
identity is intertwined the moon is only
bright because it reflects the sunshine
and I'm not entirely convinced I even
write these lines because my DNA is
coated by divine design but if I
manifest abundance while Humanity is
dying
I'm equally responsible for all that I'm
denying see you can tell the truth and
still be lying I did it for years my
perception was a funhouse mirror and my
projection was exaggerated on reality
too my reflection back was nothing more
than technicality so Who am I
if I'm not who I am what if I didn't
have my name or my age or my friends if
I didn't do my poetry who would I be
then the things that I've become or not
the things I truly am and everything I
think our own owns me in the end
existence doesn't owe me anything quite
the opposite existence will exist long
after I am missed so the art is more
important than the artist is it's not a
human race it's just the human race
there's nothing left to chase we do not
run this place but both medicine and
poisons an acquired taste so I started
taking selfies of somebody else's face
right before I died I'm gonna tell a
joke so that everyone in my bedside can
laugh before I croak most apart on
somber notes but life is serious enough
and we take our seriousness so serious
for what
just because we're serious doesn't mean
we're tough it requires more courage to
laugh when times get rough because
laughter doubles as an outlet if energy
is stuck it can disrupt your pattern
long enough to shift how you look and if
you shift how you look you shift how you
look that way people see you differently
in a changes [ __ ] up the glass is either
half-empty
or half filled up I'm just grateful that
I have a cup so many brag about how they
don't give a [ __ ] because they have no
[ __ ] to give me I give so many [ __ ]
that you would think I have none left
but my [ __ ] are exponential so I'll
give until my death
cuz I'll have infinite [ __ ] into my
very last breath and that's when I'll
tell my joke and it will be so good that
the waiting room will laugh like they
never knew they could and they'll have
to tell their friends and their friends
will laugh too and pretty soon the whole
city will be laughing at the truth and
they'll laugh until they cry and they'll
cry until they scream and they'll scream
until they love and their love until
they dream it was just a little joke I
didn't know what it could mean it was
just a little joke now the joke is on me
because the laughter was contagious so
it spread across the land my punchline
was so outrageous people couldn't even
stand
they started rolling on the floors they
started giving up beliefs they started
begging me for more but I was already
deceased
it didn't matter rich or poor forget the
languages they speak because the heart
can understand
so what rippled through the streets and
they laugh beyond their fears and they
laugh beyond their grief and they laugh
beyond their Wars they laugh themselves
right into peace we are pieces in the
puzzle but we've never seen the box
we're addicted to the struggle it's a
[ __ ] paradox but I put that in my
joke so the irony was obvious no mirrors
and no smoke the clarity was so
hilarious that people [ __ ] choked
then they laughed everybody throw your
hands up people talking Joe everybody
put yeah
now go like this people [ __ ] chuck
then they laughed about the choking
uba's universal dope that humanity was
smoking in two minutes
she was open overwhelmed by their
emotions they heard the laughter coming
from the mountains in the ocean
they heard the laughter coming from the
skies and trees even the universe was
laughing as it fell to its knees and
right then the laughter stopped it was
almost all at once at first it was a
shock the transition was abrupt but
eventually they settled in united in
their work they had a lot to do together
as they built a better earth I never saw
it happen but I was sure it did I helped
my wife and kids hands as I closed my
eyelids and I dreamt about this world in
the things we could create if I could
find the right joke before my soul
evacuates so I opened up my mouth but I
had nothing left to say so my joke was
in the silence I slowly slipped away
[Laughter]
if you guys feel alive say yeah so I was
coming out of my new therapists office
the other day this is totally true and
sitting in the waiting room was my old
therapist my first thought was I must
have made the right decision I haven't
seen him in a few years and it was like
immediately awkward so there was an
uncomfortable silence I was like hey man
how are you he was like I'm good how are
you I was like I'm good and then there
was another silence and I just said
alright man we you know take care and he
was like yeah you too man and I walked
away thinking we are all going through
this human [ __ ] together aren't we
this is called one little dot how can
something this big be invisible the
environment is everywhere and yet it
isn't visible maybe if we saw it we
would see it's not invincible and have
to take responsibilities individuals how
can something this big be invisible if
it's all around us it should show itself
on pure principle the scientists are
certain that the damage is residual and
climate change data is reaching levels
that are critical yet somehow that's
political we argue over math our
citizens are too cynical to believe in
facts we make excuses and hold on to the
recent past we don't want to sacrifice
so we refuse to ask I grew up in a city
it's all I ever knew so even now I have
nothing to compare it to I have to hit
the park to see more than a tree or two
I have to visit nature like it's in a
[ __ ] zoo
but California was wild before the
parking lots before the mass malls
before designer shops before the strip
clubs before the sea change when
mountain lions roam freely over freeways
before the fast-food before the freeze
frames we live around a bunch of dead
[ __ ] these days
you with me it's not an argument for
better or worse it's an observation on
how we've been treating Mother Earth and
we always seem to mistreat the ones we
love first but we protect what is ours
my land my life my house my kids my job
my wife my dog my car my country my
culture but when it comes to nature our
perspective is external the planet the
forest the ocean these skies the
mountains the valleys always be
nevermind if it's not me never mind
I'm too busy all the time and without
the ownership we ignore the warning
signs just look at all the species on
the planet that are dying the coral
reefs the honey bees mysteriously dying
one-fourth of all the mammals that exist
are dying 1/3 of all an phibian czar at
the risk of dying we're on a path to
mass extinction it's almost like we're
trying because we're relying on an
atmosphere that we've been frying I
could use more statistics but you
probably think I'm lying because over
half the politicians we elect deny them
well since when did their opinions
outweigh the science
I thought experiments are fundamentally
unbiased capitalism uses nature as its
example and excuse for competition the
only problem is we've removed it from
the ecosystem profit and balance in the
arkad are attainable but growth without
a conscience is completely unsustainable
a lion doesn't kill all the gazelles why
do we have to have it all to ourselves
pretty soon there'll be nothing left but
concrete and cars and when you see an
animal
it'll be like seeing a movie star the
planet deep for us the ocean these skies
the mountains the valleys always the
never mind if it's not me never mind
I'm too busy all the time and without
the ownership we ignore the warning
signs our planet are forced our ocean
our skies our mountains our valleys
always we always mind my planet my
forest my ocean my skies my mountains my
valleys always we always mine always
ours always yours
[Music]
[Applause]
one little dot in trillions of stars one
little dot it's all that we've got we
just forgot that none of it's ours we
just forgot that all of its ours
one little dot in trillions of stars
my name is ink you thank you so much for
listening appreciate it
[Applause]
and now it is my absolute pleasure to
introduce the man of the hour to the
stage he's somebody that I very much
respect and admire and I also consider
him a friend
so give a huge huge round of applause a
lot of [ __ ] love give it up one time
for Rich roll
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
imagine walking out onto a stage after
that guy being expected to talk let's
give it up for n Q one more time what a
beautiful gift of the humanity of an is
and for the boys Tyler Trapper Harry and
Dylan I might have shed a tear backstage
of Pride watching them play tonight it's
a it's a gift and it's an honor to be up
here with all of you this evening this
event has been long in the making and I
visualized it many times and it just
warms my heart to see so many people
turn up tonight so that we can
collectively experience ideas and a
level of consciousness that together
we've collectively experienced but only
in the digital space tonight is about
analog it's about community it's about
communication it's about connectivity
and intimacy and I just appreciate
everybody being here tonight so before
we get into it I had like a whole like
speech that I was going to give and I
decided to toss that out because I
received an email yesterday and for
those of you that listen to the show you
know like I'd like to read emails from
time to time and I thought that it would
be good to read this one because the
person who sent it to me happens to be
here this evening so bear with me this
is from Ron Ron writes hi rich I'm
headed to LA tomorrow to join you for
the live podcast event and very excited
for the experience we met at the
conscious capitalism CEO summit coming
on two years ago we had lunch with a
small group and I shared with you
afterwards that my 16 year old son was
in treatment for drug and alcohol
addiction you said the greatest thing to
me and that was Wow
what I would have been able to have done
my life if I learned the recovery skills
at 16 versus 40 wrote 40 was actually 31
but and that comment gave me hope I also
started listening to your podcast on a
regular basis and it has been part of my
journey to be a better father husband
and leader I get to share that through
my involvement as the founder and board
chair of conscious capitalism Kansas
City so thank you jumping back to this
week my son that I mentioned will be in
the audience with me he is now 18 he's
been accepted to LMU in Los Angeles for
fall of to 2020 he is at LMU this week
taking part in the dedication of their
new lions for recovery center in the
Student Union and speaking on a panel
sharing his story right
and this is the part that got me so you
were right and I learned that recovery
gives expansion and not contraction
recovery gives expansion and not
contraction I appreciate you for being a
light and inspiration to us to live
better lives and create a better world
with gratitude
Ron Ron Hill are you here can you stand
up and wave and your son Alec I can't
see the crowd but there you are
beautiful thank you
[Music]
this is why I do what I do this is my
sustenance beyond the simple sort of
personal gratification of hosting a
podcast and and being able to have the
privilege of being in conversation with
so many amazing people
it's messages like that that really are
my energy this is an act of service and
and so thank you for that message that
really kept me going and it's an honor
to be able to share that with everyone
tonight
as I said tonight is about community
it's about connectivity and in mulling
over that theme it has me thinking about
the humble origins of this show it's
very surreal for me to be up on a stage
talking to you tonight and I can't do
this without thinking back to the very
beginning of this show it was about
seven years ago it started in a
warehouse with perhaps the worst
acoustics ever on the North Shore of a
Hawaiian island called kawaii and I
believe at the time I was feeling a
little bit lonely I was having a little
bit of island fever I'd written a book
that had come out some months prior and
was feeling a little bit of a void and I
had this creative impulse to try to plug
back into humanity by plugging a
microphone into a recorder and just
starting to talk and I did that for no
other reason than curiosity and a desire
to connect with other people and I loved
it and it was something that I never
thought would ever transcend just being
a simple hobby but here we are seven
years later about five hundred episodes
in maybe a thousand hours of
conversations that have brought us here
together tonight it's unbelievable and
in reflecting over the course of this
seven years and all the conversations
that I've been blessed to have it's
taught me so much about life about how
to make decisions about how to be
a sober human a dad a husband a
responsible member of society about how
to live a fulfilling purposeful life but
I would say I'd probably forgotten way
more than I've learned but a couple
themes have emerged that are very clear
and those themes are community
connectivity if we want to grow if we
want to expand recovery begets expansion
not contraction when we think about that
word recovery let's broaden the aperture
let's expand the definition of that word
recovery it doesn't have to be limited
to overcoming substance abuse let's just
call it growth growth begets expansion
growth begets expansion and that journey
of personal growth requires a level of
personal responsibility but true healing
true growth over the long term is a
group effort
it happens with community it happens
collectively it is a team sport and as
gratifying as the podcast has been in
truth it's an abstraction because it
lives in the ether in the cloud I have
people come over to my house some weeks
or months later it gets uploaded to the
Internet people enjoy it through their
earbuds I'm so grateful that it's made
an impact on people but it's still an
abstraction and it's an abstraction for
me and this called a community to
cultivate greater connection and
intimacy is what spawned the idea of
having this events to have an analog
experience to gather all of these
like-minded people who are blazing this
path that I'm on let's get in a room
together and let's connect so before we
get into the show
let's take a moment I want everybody
here to turn to their neighbor not their
friend that they came with but whoever
sitting behind you or in front of you
somebody that you don't know I want you
to introduce yourself and I want you to
tell that person what lights you up what
gets you excited about life
yes this is what it's about
[Applause]
see my dad my parents up there
how many of you went on the group run
this morning that Billy yank put
together incredible that's what I'm
talking about Wow when the lights went
up I realized how many people are here
and I started get freaked out all right
we got to keep this moving so we have a
great show for you tonight before we get
into it I want to take a brief moment to
thank my incredible team of people that
worked
tires tirelessly to pull this evening
off and also who I work with on a daily
and a weekly basis to create the podcast
if you listen to the show you've
probably heard their names many many
times I wanted to put a face to those
names so I'm gonna call them out and I
want you guys to give them a hearty
round of applause so first of all Jason
camiolo my audio engineer and
jack-of-all-trades he came in from
Phoenix today I don't know where he is
but yeah let's put the house lights off
back there right margo Lubin where's
Margo there she is handling video Blake
Curtis
who's there there's Blake where's Chris
Swann
there he is back there Chris is the og
I've been working with him since the
very beginning Ali Rogers on the galleys
backstage right here she's doing some
video work for us
Jessica Miranda who creates all the
beautiful graphics for the show she is
there she's there she is
beautiful Jessica
Jonathan Rhett sack and our ex our
sports he's the man behind creating this
whole event for this evening thank you
Jonathan
DK David Khan hashtag DK goals how's it
going brother
he keeps the wheels creased my business
partner Greg Anzalone special place in
my heart for Greg's he is the engine
behind everything I'm able to create
last but not least my beautiful wife
Julie she's right here to fire a KA
Srimati this doesn't happen without her
my daughter Jaya sitting next to her hi
Jaya my dad is here tonight my parents
are here today who enjoy my podcast with
my dad the guy said he's up in the Loews
up there he said he's gone like this he
doesn't want to attention my mom and my
sister all right thank you we are gonna
get into the main event now we are so
blessed to have an extraordinary
legendary guest for tonight's
conversation you know his name his name
is Paul Hawken he is a pioneering
environmentalist and entrepreneur an
architect of corporate reform with
respect to ecological practices a
multiple New York Times bestselling
author and activist who has dedicated
his life to environmental sustainability
and changing the relationship between
business and the environment his work
includes founding successful
ecologically conscious businesses like
erawan which we're going to talk about
writing about the impacts of commerce on
living systems and consulting with heads
of state and CEOs on economic
development industrial ecology and
environmental policy Paul is the
executive director of project drawdown
which is an extraordinary nonprofit
dedicated to researching when and how
global warming can be reversed in
addition to countless op-eds
and peer-reviewed articles paul has
written eight books four bestsellers
including drawdown the most
comprehensive plan ever proposed to
reverse global warming he's an amazing
human his bio goes on for like 20
paragraphs so I think I'm gonna leave it
at that he has lectured everywhere
including Harvard Stanford and wort and
he's given commencement addresses at
Yale and Berkeley he's appeared on Bill
our Charlie Rose Larry King basically
everywhere it is a gift to have him here
tonight so we're gonna watch a little
video and we're gonna bring them out as
we continue to set it up but let's hear
it for Paul Hawken everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
well the warning isn't happening to us
it's happening for us
the gift every system without feedback
dies
this is feedback the gift is an offering
to reimagine who we are how we relate
what matters and what we can create with
our minds the parts are brilliant
[Music]
[Applause]
how you doing ball and then great I'm so
happy to be with the rich role that I've
been having controlling my ear buds for
two years and I'm a connoisseur I can
review it I just love and I'm so
grateful for it's more than a podcast I
mean that's how it comes to us but it's
it's to me it's an exploration which
sets breadth and depth and mm-hmm I find
myself wanting turning on a podcast
where I'm not really interested in that
okay and then I am and because because
of the way you interact with that person
the fact on that person actually mmm
opens up to you in a way that I don't
think they do normally or maybe they do
but you know it's for me it's like so
singular and I just want to acknowledge
that and thank you because it just shows
I think he's talking about recovery but
I mean with all due respect we all need
to recover we're all addicted and to one
thing or another in this culture and so
I think it's exemplary what you're doing
and how you've manifested that so thank
you I appreciate that and blushing we
can end the podcast now we're good Wow
thank you it is is truly an honor to be
able to have this conversation with you
tonight and I think it's it's so
prescient because we're in the middle of
an extraordinary moment right now in
terms of climate activism and awareness
we saw some historic activity over the
last week with the beautiful Greta
visiting our shores and so I think the
best place to kind of launch into this
is is hearing a little bit about how you
think about what's happening right now
like where are we right now and how are
you thinking about the movement and the
prognosis for the future given what
we've seen over the last few weeks
well I'm glad you use the word prognosis
because it's come to be the people think
diagnosis is prognosis and mostly what
we hear about is diagnosis it's as if we
went to a doctor for annual checkup and
he says you have a you know a
life-threatening disease and this is the
disease and in detail and this is
probably how long you can live and then
gives you an invoice and says see yeah I
mean that's what we're doing to each
other because we're just getting
assaulted by the science which is
impeccable mm-hmm argue with the science
but at what point do you have enough of
it to know that you have to do something
or not but you're gonna have to do
something and I feel like that this week
was really about the fact that the world
has become woke and and actually nothing
happened much in the atmosphere from one
week to the right before what happened
is what happened is to us I mean we
whoever we are but I mean there was a
sense in the media for once is no longer
doing fair and balanced coverage which
is to turn the microphone to a denier
mm-hmm you don't see that anymore
it's actually clip something has changed
but underneath that though what hasn't
changed is basically that's still based
on pure threat and doom and we know what
happens when we make people afraid and
they shut down their make the little
lights up I mean the whole survival
thing comes up I mean he was right there
I mean his poem about that I mean and so
and our prefrontal cortex shuts down
which is the problem-solving part of our
brain and so from my point of view and
I've been as I'm an English major so no
scientist but I address and in watching
and reading the coverage on climate for
three decades and inside I just felt
like I wouldn't say it that way I
wouldn't communicate that way I wouldn't
use that ever I think that's the wrong
verb I'm just like I'm committing to no
one and
no one heard me but I I kept thinking I
don't think this is really working for
us you know and I feel like it still
isn't by the way because 99% of the
world is disengaged and we still have a
world where people if they go see a
documentary on climate change they think
they've done something you know yep and
so right right I mean my sense is sorry
I don't mean to interrupt my sense is
that we saw this groundswell of civic
activity over the last couple weeks
people pouring out into the streets a
level it's like we're at a tipping point
in terms of of civic mindedness and
awareness and an activation but I feel
like the story is all about is still all
about trying to get the powers that be
at the top to implement change whereas
the people aren't left with that many
solutions that they can implement in
their own lives so it's a top-down
solution as opposed to what you're
always talking about which is the middle
path like the solution that's in the
middle yeah I really do think it's the
middle middle out solution middle out
manifestation yes in your climate week
this last week and the top was there
CEOs and heads of NGOs and heads of
state as you and we you know as well and
and there is a sea change no question
about it
it's as if they a lot of people suddenly
particularly the corporate side woke up
and you had two weeks before that you
had you know Jamie Dimon from JPMorgan
saying with the Business Council you
know saying basically shares more
there's things more important than this
child without you which you know but I
mean that they said it under the biggest
corporations in the world and a lot of
that was happening in New York where you
had these trillion multi trillion-dollar
commitments from different
configurations of the business and
governmental world however having said
that I hope it all happens I have hope
it happens faster but I still think
we've been looking for love in all the
wrong places
I mean the conference of the parties
which is in Chile Santiago this year
it's a 25th one when we started drawdown
project Rada in a 20-30 min of the 2015
excuse me we saw in 2015 in 2015 there
was the Paris agreement before the Paris
agreement I had lots of friends there
staff there and I said ask anyone if
they know the top ten solutions in any
order to reversing global warming and
the fact is after 30 40 plus years of
being the public sphere
no one knew I mean this is phenomenal
that we didn't know to what do you
account for that lack of awareness like
that that like inability to focus on
solutions we're very good on what's
actually happening and the science of
what's causing all of this why the
glaring omission when it comes to
solution based activity up until
drawdown I think it several reasons one
is that we started with impact like or
making an impact we have cars burning
coal and so I think it was very much
dominated by men the whole climate
conversation the science you know the
solutions and well we have to stop
making so much impact well yeah I mean
deaths reduction lessening no it's just
slow down it's you know and so that was
one of the conversation but basically
society led by men was looking at impact
in the reduction of impact well that
impact is about greenhouse gases going
up there
and so obviously we have to stop putting
him up in the atmosphere but there was
nothing about bringing him back home
mm-hmm and the conversation and from
very well on people don't need to name
them was about solar wind and solar wind
and recently Elon Musk and somehow if we
did those three we got a Hall Pass to
the 22nd century and that's just
scientific nonsense those are crucial
solutions the first two but we haven't
really seen it in a holistic systemic
way as a system that causes it as
assistant
and we tend to look at it very if you
break something into pieces
and try to fix the pieces you haven't
fixed anything David qualms and had a
great thing about if you take a Persian
rug and cut it into 1-inch squares
it's just unraveling a wool it's not
Persian carpet and that's what we've
kind of done and so what it's done I
think to individuals is either what it's
sold it win to think well I hope they do
it I mean because I can't do that I
can't do a solar farm or wind turbine in
the ocean
and so in a way it's been disempowering
because then the solutions of
individuals will recycle or ride a bike
and you know less you know put use cold
water in your laundry and even the Union
of Concerned Scientists had a list and
one of the things on the list of what
you could do right ways to put a power
strip in your home entertainment center
I'm coming and unless you have an IQ
lower the room temperature when you read
when you read that list of what you can
do the listen falero we're screwed you
know we're screwed
yeah I mean it's it's inadequate to the
task at hand and so in a way it's been
sort of patronizing to individuals and
so don't worry the experts going to take
care of it
and well wait a minute you know and so I
I feel like the in the media still
really propagates this it's there all
the Democratic candidates where they
talk about energy energy energy they
threw a little corn cob to the Midwest
for farming but I mean it it really
wasn't about the whole solution and the
whole solution is so much more
interesting I think what the science
about climate change is much worse than
we know and the solution what's meat and
well let me raise is that the solutions
are much better both are true when you
say this science is much worse a lot
right now science is great I mean that
is what's going to happen the radio oh
yeah I think it's still being Tanna huh
well I think it would be worthwhile to
kind of walk us up to the process of
drawdown like what led you to this and
how you put this team together to try to
actually do the math and figure out what
the most effective solutions would be
well the it started in 2001 with a third
assessment came out from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change and like every assessment or more
dire and pessimistic than the prior and
the reason for that is that they're
based on consensus science which of
course there's no such thing as
consensus science science is evidentiary
and you don't agree like I don't have a
but you know if a functional medicine
doctor talking to you know how a patent
doctor and say well let's come to an
agreement about how to treat cancer it's
not gonna work and that's essentially
what the IPCC was you had you know the
Saudis and the Russians and earlier the
Chinese and the Venezuelans are going on
everything's cool you know you know tamp
it down and that's why each one has been
more pessimistic because the data
support said there's three billion data
points in the next assessment is coming
up and so the data is extraordinary but
I think that in 2001 I've read the third
assessment summary and then at that time
simultaneously or a few months later out
of Princeton came the carbon mitigation
project which was these seven wedges
that were comprised of 15 solutions and
of we engendered and enacted those
solutions each wedge was a billion
gigatonnes of carbon not co2 carbon and
then we could stabilize emissions by
2050 and everybody who read it in the
media like yeah we're on it and I'm me
too it's like oh wow good old Princeton
University and and then I read the
solutions and 11 of those solutions I
kid you not could only be adopted by the
boards of directors of super
conservative corporations eight of them
being coal gas and oil the ninth one
being utility the tenth one being a car
company and the lever fund being a big
appliance company and each one of those
solutions who is deeply underwater
financially which means what they were
saying is that the boards of directors
would have to basically spend down their
balance sheet and get sued for their
gonna happen here and there's only one
and a half things that you and I could
do which is drive less and put a solar
panel on our
or something and agency was left out and
there was no agency to it you know what
about teachers what about schools what
about small companies what about farmers
were about foresters we're the red
grazers read about ranchers you know
what about cities what about towns I
mean all that was left out and I thought
and that's when I started to go around
to NGOs and universities I know and two
things or what can we name the goal you
guys to this day but you guys are using
verbs as goals like mitigating I'm sorry
not a goal
combating doesn't work for me fighting
those aren't goals and so I wanted to
name the goal which is to stop going the
wrong direction turn around and go the
other way which means that first time on
a year-to-year basis where greenhouse
gases peak and go down that strata how
dare you I know nobody I mean nobody was
talking about bringing it down it's all
about slowing down the emissions trying
to get to neutral or zero but no
conversations about how we're actually
going to reduce that and pull that
carbon out of the atmosphere nice to
have sequester I know I was and I said
need the map measurement model the
hundred most substantive solutions to
reversing or warming every said what a
great idea we don't do that I went to
big NGOs and said why don't you do it I
said if I knew how to do it I'm gonna be
a skier and and and so and and finally I
stopped asking until 2013 so you put
together this incredible team know every
c-13 actually an article came out in
Rolling Stone from Bill McKibben right
global warming's terrifying new math and
what he had done is taken to work by
mark on finale in London as carbon
tracker and mark measure he measured he
was a financial analyst and so he
analyzed the balance sheet of every coal
gas and oil company in the world they
gave his balance sheet he could get a
hands on some of them you can like in
Russia and so forth and and he coined
the term unburnable carbon because he
said your kindnesses assets on your
balance sheet but if we burn it you know
basically we're Venus so how could this
be valuable in fact we wouldn't even be
here to burn it by that time and so what
bill mckibben did in Rolling Stone was
burn it so that was why it was global
warming's terrifying new math and I had
so many friends come to me using the
same language which is game over we we
tried we did our best we worked hard but
it's game over and the thought occurred
to me it kind of relates to recovery in
addiction and says sometimes when it's
game over
it's actually surrender it's like I
don't know what to do or you know and I
thought this is actually a teachable
moment when people give up and that's
why I started to draw down and I just
knew that if it was staged on the stage
you know it was like a white charismatic
male vertebrate telling the rest of the
world listen up I know what to do I mean
that's just so over so dead so nothing
yeah I mean the problem or is because
white semi charismatic male vertebrates
have told us what to do
and that clearly didn't work and so and
so I felt there had to be a we had to be
a we talking to we you know let's have a
conversation together community
collaboration connection you know and so
we got research fellows from all over
the world 21 countries almost half women
have PhDs all the major religions and
it's just an amazing group of young
people astonishing 128 advisers
everybody from you know religious
leaders and political leaders and
governors to even Tom Brady from them
yeah Patriots I mean he's really
collecting and then 60 outside
scientific reviewers to review our
models so what we wanted to do is
present something that was pretty much
bulletproof you know in terms of
scotches you know because the scientific
community is such a concert community
and it's held up actually this hasn't
been one criticism of the data sensor
not in April 2017 but it's conservative
a section conservative yeah you make
these conservative estimates you're
working with the median numbers not the
extremes on it on either side but talk a
little bit about the expectations that
you had going into it you know as a
scientist you're trying to be neutral
but I'm sure you had imagined what these
top solutions were going to look like so
contrast that expectation versus what
you actually discover yeah well remember
I said in Paris I was at that point we I
could tell [ __ ] I don't know not that I
knew that I don't know oh my gosh like
how could I not know how could we not
know I mean after all this time they're
meeting in Paris they're signing the
agreement and we didn't know until two
months before a pop date what the
siller's the ranking and the reason that
his models are never finished they're
about the future and therefore
inherently wrong yeah but you're going
into it thinking it's gonna be so
location solar you know energy energy
energy and and your vector models so
they all interact so you can't pull one
out and say okay that's the biggest one
and we designed the book we had it all
on a hard drive it's all ready to go
just stick it into a printing press so
we can wait till the last moment to put
in the numbers uh-huh impact and we were
shocked I was shocked and the number one
solutions refrigerant management and I
was so disappointed it's not sexy no
that's the point
and as an air-conditioning basic well
who's gonna write the mysteries you know
and I could believe it explained this
why are we not talking about the number
one thing because it's not sexy because
there's not much we can do about it and
because we don't understand it I mean
refrigerant gases are 1 to 10,000 times
more powerful than co2 and they're just
all over the world you know the
eeeek and then when they're recycled
they're not actually the gases escape
and so that's number one number two is
wind turbine which is expected em hmm
but I didn't see number three coming
which is reduce food waste food wasting
their food waste is huge
so let's let's spend a little time
talking about that because the impact of
that is is so massive and it seems like
the solution to that is extremely doable
well what's wonderful about that
solution is that everybody sitting here
with us tonight eats two or three times
a day or maybe more about at least two
or three times so it makes you conscious
three times a day about your
relationship to land food farming
atmosphere self health other I mean it's
quite extraordinary
I mean it's and it's not just what you
choose to eat it's what from the food is
nervous where did it come from and the
farming in the soil because soil is
absolutely the number one solution to
reversing global warming not refrigerant
management and I can get I can get into
that but with the we waste a third of
the world's food the the the industrial
AG companies for years have said if we
don't basically poison the earth and
kill it with herbicides and pesticides
we're gonna run out of food mm-hmm but
they're saying is trust us we're gonna
kill more and more life to have more
life I mean that's once a knows in
Toronto that Syngenta Dow and of course
that is so upside down and backwards so
I mean it's extraordinary but we don't
need more farmland actually we need less
and we 97% of all soybean production
goes into confined area feeding
operations to raise pig house I mean
come on
and and I mean that's just for starters
go to corn
it's the same and so we have been we've
sort of bought into this whole thing if
we focus on food waste we have more than
enough food for not only a population
that exists right now but for the nine
to ten billion that are expected by 22
yeah well a couple things I mean what's
interesting about the food waste
discussion is that it's coming in so
high in this ranking and yet you're not
even accounting for all the methane
that's produced by the food waste going
into the landfill like you left that out
of it if you were to factor that in it
would be even higher on the web I'd love
that you did your homework
that's absolutely true the reason we
didn't include it is because we didn't
have the data right but absolutely once
it goes into a landfill becomes
anaerobic methane is 28 times more
powerful than co2 other greenhouse gas
and if we add add add in that was Volta
number one solution by far and that's
just the tip of the veritable hay-bale
you know in terms of impact of food is
is really a to the top 20 solution of
the top twenty solution or super food
related yeah so if you take all of those
eight and add them up it becomes the
number one thing by far and to what
extent is that Trump transportation and
energy yep I mean it's a multiple of
that right in terms of reversing global
warming not in terms of emissions is
necessarily best remember that means to
actually bring carbon back home
and because it's the only solution that
actually is able to take the carbon down
and put it somewhere right remove it
from the atmosphere so it's working on
both sides of the equations been doing
it for three and a half billion years
photosynthesis chlorophyll you know
microalgae phytoplankton I mean that's
what it does you know right to this day
and I go back to what I said about
impact remember I felt like remember
some of you may remember there's this
movie Close Encounters of the Third
Devils Postpile you know and this little
flying saucer came down and Richard
Dreyfuss is greatest roles you know
looking at it and going yeah you know we
contacted you know the second kind not
the third kind and then behind them the
mothership is coming up you know behind
them and they turn around I just found
out the other day somebody was at the
shooting they're looking a little piece
of tape on the wall when they did they
turn around go ah there's a little piece
of tape it was CGI of course but I mean
here's this mothership coming up in
there
so the mothership here is the mothership
the biggest solution to reversing global
warming isn't in the city isn't you know
our cars isn't all that we have to
crucially stop putting it up there its
soil forests and oceans mmm it's
extraordinary we can sequester a
trillion tons of co2 by regenerative
farming practices we have to increase if
we crease by a half percent of searle
organic carbon our grasslands and for us
I'm not forests in our farms mm-hmm
that's a trillion tons of co2 that takes
us back to 1870 just to give you a sense
of dimension and the Swiss EHT the
Federal Institute assistant cannot agree
with report two months ago from the
Crowther lab that said and they studied
with using Google nob like these two
hectare or five acre plots all over the
world and identified in five countries
where we could put 800 million acres of
new forests that would sequester 750
billion tons of co2 and finally are
those the oceans and nothing sequester's
carbon faster think help it's nothing
and there's another trillion tons that's
2.75 trillion tons I mean that would
make us again Mars so we're not gonna do
that because there's three point three
trillion tons up there but I wanna count
on the numbers so much as to give us a
sense of what the breadth and depth of
what we can do and it lies within life
look creating the conditions go by right
so so in the book you have these hundred
solutions 80 of them are vetted with
science and then you have this section
on coming attractions and I think there
was two super fascinating ones in there
for me and one you just touch on which
is the marine phytoplankton like sort of
you know creating permaculture in our
oceans yes but there's this crazy story
that you tell about discovering that
cows that a kelp had methane would like
this incredible reduction in their
methane emissions right and so this idea
is baked to feed them this algae that
they that comes from Hawaii or something
like that and they feed the cows this
and then it resolves the methane problem
like explain this to make sure it
happened that started in Prince Edward
Island in Canada where a farmer every
farm virtually is on the coast it's such
a small island quite and he noticed that
the dairy cows were eating kelp
somewhere somewhere it produced more
milk so why Annie called his County
agent who said not sure let me get a
scientist in there and so they brought
in a scientist and he said it must be
because of reduce methane metabolism
because methane actually is a pirate I
mean it got aboard
you know ruminants a long time ago it's
not innate to being a room and it is now
and it's very inefficient metabolically
that is to say it doesn't do anything
much for the cow although she protocol
and so they split the herd and kelp no
kelp and they put plastic bags on their
head five times a day and measured
exhalations and sure enough there was
less methane exhalation from the cows
ate a cow and more milk well that's what
you call a science project yeah good
science but doesn't mean anything
because you can't feed the cows or the
sheep or the goats in the world kelp but
that scientists heard of a scientist in
Australia who was doing the same or had
the same observation
and together they discovered that there
was an algae called
asparagus Aztecs reformist it grows
actually in the whole tropical belt of
the world that a Fed to ruminants
reduces methane emissions from 50 to 90
percent you know and I mean methane
emissions from you know animals is a
heat fortress Olivarez yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean that's I know but you know
what this tells us IV I thought I don't
think we know the good news remember I
said the solutions are better than we
know mm-hmm I mean the rate of
innovation and I'm nothing about direct
air capture and these kind of silly
things you know we're gonna replace
trees and capture carbon I'm talking
about their rate of brilliance and
innovation is happening in the world
today with respect to all aspects of
what we do including regenerative
agriculture which is just exploding in
terms of techniques it's not technology
techniques and breakthroughs is is truly
extraordinary that's I mean I'm not
plugging it but that's why I'm doing the
next book regeneration you know says
ending the climate crisis in one
generation because we don't know about
these solutions right but one of one of
the amazing things about a lot of these
solutions if not all of them is the
compounding impact of them right like
you write about the fact that even if
these solutions weren't reducing your
carbon and weren't part of the global
warming solution that they're still good
ideas they and they empower communities
economically they create jobs they're
treating the planet better it's not just
it's not a binary thing right I mean I
think the algae story is you know
exemplifies that very sir because you
get higher productivity I think that
there's no question that if you take the
solutions and draw down and you we
didn't have a say a climate scientist
was we didn't even have a high mythology
okay
we're clueless we didn't understand
where extreme weather came from or what
was caused by we just had a you know
hurricane durian whoo
and we would want to do all these
solutions because of their second third
fourth fifth six order effects that are
beneficial in terms of water health
education prosperity children I mean it
just it just goes right took tick tick
tick tick project I'm the only exception
to that in my opinion is nuclear uh-huh
all right well coming in hot at number
four the plant rich diet yeah is this
not a euphemism for eating a plant-based
diet come on Paul you just got to take
that extra bleep I thought there like I
thought plan okay show the hands for
plant rich I think plant rich was more
enticing the people frankly because rich
III could I feel yeah I feel ya you
don't want to alienate anyone at all
it's okay I felt like in order to model
we had to have a methodology that was
straight up and down and the thing that
surprises people about darada is we
never advocated for anything it's odd
you say well of course you didn't no he
didn't
there's no advocate there's no [ __ ] must
need to know because then they I don't
feel like bad or they didn't really
could but they can't all that sort of
stuff we use no fear threaten doom you
didn't blame anybody even shame anybody
we didn't demonize anybody I said right
in the introduction this is not right we
think it's approximately right because
when you're right you make somebody
wrong I'm right then but the fact though
somebody else is wrong because what you
could be right about and so one of the
things we didn't do also is advocate and
the reason for that was we want to
create spaciousness around the subject
because the way it's been communicated
has really put people off or make them
numb or make them feel bad and so we
want to communicate in such a way that
actually drew
into it and it played out it's taught
from every grade from fourth grade fifth
sixth seventh all the way to MIT
graduate school Harvard Graduate School
Stanford UC Berkeley sent 14 languages
it's in the second-biggest hotel chain
New Zealand along with the Gideon Bible
in every room it just goes on and on Wow
and I in its telling better now than it
did two and half years ago the biggest
print this 12th printing was the biggest
printing so far by the way this is a
book that penguin did not want to print
because your books don't sell but the
the point being is I feel like if you
create spaciousness for people to come
in and and make up their own mind and
get interested in narratives and stories
and so forth you're doing you're going
to do much better than if you hammer
them and say if you don't do something
or we undo something we're screwed and
that may be true in a kind of
interesting way but it doesn't it's
ineffective and so I'm always trying to
think how do you create this
spaciousness so it's not a duality you
know I'm you know and and I mean ink use
his poetry is about non-duality right
and and so duality is really the core
dis-ease that we have you know and when
we say combating climate change or I'm
gonna fix it you know I mean or we're
gonna fight it you know it's so crazy
because it's like there's an if
somewhere I'm gonna go like this right
now okay yeah okay this is it right this
is the atmosphere go fight it and tackle
it as you will
climates not the problem we're the
problem where the problem is a human
problem and we actually want the clients
to change we're trying to get it to
change in a different direction if it
doesn't rescue you so it does we needed
to change the question is we need to
change what we do and how we relate to
each other and down here in order to
stabilize the climate and that's what
driver yeah well this this stems from
and you've talked about this a lot this
the sense of other other night when we
look at the at the climate or our
environment as something that's other or
or other individuals and what they're
doing
as other as opposed to embracing the you
know unifying holistic nature you know
of oneness that we all are that's what
we need to step into and to really to
really like grok the solution here we
all grew up with a conditioned mind that
basically steals our joy if we let it
yeah
and that conditioned mind first of all
it's like we're an individual uh-huh
well so here's here's here's a question
for you as a man of science and I'm and
and somebody who worked very hard with
their team to to create this here we
should show it for those who haven't
seen it this this beautiful book that's
so inviting that you can read if you're
in fourth grade or you're a PhD student
it's all very organized and digestible
and it's about the data and the math how
do you square being this man of science
with your you know for Buddhist leanings
and your spiritual perspective on how we
solve these problems well I'm not a man
of science a man of science appreciation
I'm a journalist okay yeah I don't think
I would have done well in science at all
and the Buddhist perspective is really
one of really obviously used terms
mindfulness and you know awareness I'm a
really piss-poor Buddhist so I just want
to put that out there I know some that
are fantastic and I only you know bow to
them every time I can jack Kornfield a
friend I just think he's an incredible
teacher and but the but the the the the
the basic teachings are about practice
about what to become if you understand
that
identity and if you confused about
identity I am fill in the blank you're
confused hmm basically and then from
that confusion arises actions that are
inappropriate or unskillful or
harmful or unkind and the generosity
arises from that transcendence kindness
arises from that compassion arises from
that and I feel like this this situation
we're in the most gnarly super wicked
problem humanity has ever described and
may ever face if there's we still here
is actually a blessing and that occurs
it's I mean you can look at it like it's
happening to me and say I'm a victim and
be pissed off and then you live your
life in that mind that's the mind you
living that's the world you're living in
and that's kind of a hell realm and if
we look at it from the point of view its
feedback and from the atmosphere but
actually from the whole of the earth
because you can't really separate down
this fear from plants and for us and
water if you're looking for that way
then it's a gift it's feedback and you
take a hundred percent responsibility
you don't ask other people to do it you
take a higher percent responsible for
your actions who you are and then you
begin to imagine innovate you know you
do what incuse doing you do you know
spoken word or whatever you do things
that make sense to you that help you
connect more to this beautiful
extraordinary miracle we call the living
world and that's the gift of climate
change it's a gift is a transformation
of self and of the world and the
solutions are transformative and those
those are just some of them you know
there's a lot more and so we can either
accept the offering and the gift or we
can go into self-pity yeah yeah I mean I
think you know as I as I try that on
this idea that global warming global
climate change is happening for us as
opposed to to us and how does that feel
there is an empowerment I think with
that this sense of possibility that that
there are things that I can do you can
do we can do collectively
and then I scroll through my Twitter
feed and I see what's happening at the
highest levels of government and what's
happening with well-funded lobbyists on
K Street and the farm bill and the
subsidies and the lack of regulation and
oversight and the stripping away of
protections and all the like and all of
that goes out the window
yeah so how do you navigate that that
minefield of of what's happening in
government the things that actually you
don't you can't control you don't have
to say yeah well I mean I read the same
RSS feeds and stuff that you do every
morning I don't meet him at night and
yeah I think first of all I mean javis
has a this famous line you know fear is
the shabbiest room in the house you
deserve better conditions and and so
fear is not a place to live in it
doesn't work and so to me it's about
curiosity which is like huh look what
they did look what he said look what he
tweeted oh my gosh it's like really and
then when I spent I read the
presidential tweets ago he's talking
about himself again he's talking about
himself he said you know disgusting bad
you know corrupt you know yeah that's
true I mean I mean I thought he does he
knows himself really well yeah he really
does you know and so I say you know and
and so when I see the ignorance or the
inability to connect again if I'm going
to connect you know I become curious as
to what is the solution to that there
was what is the communication what is it
this going with it what will it take
actually and one of the things about
this week and the week prior not just
the things that Greta Duesenberg side
which was so extraordinary but I mean
this science as it was coming out is
that the sense of urgency is really
growing exponentially
which is quite interesting and I feel
like and I mean that basically and
people say well were not doing it up and
we're losing and it's happened too fast
all that sort of stuff but I think if
you actually look at the climate
movement and the rate of growth it's
growing faster than the inertial problem
of even killing the earth and we are at
that stage where I think more and more
people are going to realize that
degeneration or liquidation of the earth
actually we're coming to a dead end on
that one and so I feel like the urgency
is going to change very rapidly and
those who think they're ineffective and
I mean Zack Bush and I are on a stage
together a few weeks ago and what I said
came out I said we're rehearsing the
future knows we're rehearsing an
awareness and understanding and practice
that as people wake up they will move to
and look to in practice and an act and
it doesn't go the other way you know is
there enough time unanswerable question
will we make it unanswerable question
those questions are irrelevant what's
relevant is our hearts and who we are
and what we do and are we actually fully
engaged I mean there's no difference
between a climate denier and somebody
who's literate and climate and doesn't
do anything they both don't do anything
so what's the difference yeah beautiful
your your beginnings took place in the
civil rights movement in the world of
social justice back in 1965 with you
working with Martin Luther King in Selma
I'm interested in in how you think about
the relationship between social justice
and civil rights and environmentalism is
there a relationship there is one an
extension of the other is
environmentalism the new civil rights
like how do you think about that I don't
think environmentalism is hasn't been I
don't think it has been at all one of my
critiques of the climate communication
has been that it's very much about X's
future existential threat mm-hmm
deadline ISM 2030 if we don't do it
reduced by half we're screwed this
deadline ISM is I'm not saying it's in
Pryor but it's been going on since you
know 1990 2000 year that we've had
deadlines all of it along and we've just
been ripping pass through them through
them and I feel like that that way of
looking at the world is excludes almost
everybody because we don't think that
way most of humanity is worried about
today maybe we aren't here we're so
fortunate and so privileged and so lucky
but most of the world actually has to
worry about food about safety about
habitat about work about their children
about getting books about I mean their
everyday worries surmount everything
else and most of humanity is thinking
about what they need today and so if we
as a movement don't understand that in
order to reverse global warming we have
to actually meet
current human needs now Watson needs and
its other way around
because the only way it's going to
happen is if people billions of people
see that reversing global warming is in
their self-interest
it actually makes better food better
housing more secure in terms of safety
food security which is huge for so many
people here in this country too and so I
feel like we again have kind of looked
the wrong way we're looking at the
future come on quick you know it's gonna
happen if we don't get together and you
look behind you there's no one there 99%
as I said earlier the people in the
world that disengaged how could we
possibly do that I mean that's so inept
excuse me the science is so skillful the
communication has been so inept and that
sense of inclusion has been missing and
so if we're not addressing poverty in
the world we're not going to succeed
it's not a movement of regeneration it's
not a movement that can reverse global
warming and so there's huge benefit
there I mean in terms of inclusion in
terms of getting people you know feeling
like what they do for themselves for
their family is for their community the
biggest you had Jana Hari here you know
on your program was a beautiful podcast
but I mean he talked about addiction you
know and depression ready said the
biggest lack in the world is actually
connection and that's where the diction
is the lack of connection I think it's
affects all of us that's what we have we
don't have purpose in meaning here we
have the earth about burning up and
people are worried about progressions
and this and that
and the fact that they focus on social
media and this and not sees them all as
sort of stuff Isis it just it speaks to
the fact that people are looking for
identity and they're finding in all the
wrong places and as a as a climate
movement if you call it a movement so
forth
we haven't communicated in such a way
that everybody feels like we're together
in this thing and they get they receive
something from it not just money but
actually a sense of value that have
value and they have respect from their
children in their community that they're
doing something that is transcendent of
just an individual identity and we
haven't done that so to engender that
kind of engagement and to create a sense
of ownership over these ideas like how
do we catalyze that like how do we solve
that problem of communication to give
people more connected to it by
communication you did by action I mean
there's the one of the subtitles of
regeneration is how to create 1 billion
jobs I mean we have this situation where
we steal the future call it GDP and
congratulate ourselves and put it in the
bank I mean we can just as easily heal
the future can call that GDP that's the
choice it employs hundreds and hundreds
of millions of people to regenerate the
earth for how many people it took to
degenerated right I mean so all the work
is there it's really about action so
people feel like I have a job that is
purposeful meaningful you know so what
are what are the impediments or the
blind spots right now the blind spot the
blind spot think that's the blind spot
is is a technical fix is what a
technical fix hmm you know that there's
a technology I mean again with all due
respect to our gender you know such a
male thing you know like we're gonna fix
it and right or that we will we're just
gonna sit back and let the billionaire's
figure it out and we'll end up on on
Mars at some point oh yeah well that's
it's Silicon Valley one where I'm from
it's really curious we don't know how to
live here we're gonna figure it out yeah
[Applause]
if we're gonna terraform Mars
why don't we terraform earth well the
wonderful thing about terraforming Mars
is really that was the origin the Gaia
hypothesis Jim Lovelock he was hired by
NASA about how to create an atmosphere
I'm really literally for Mars here's
your job okay and so to figure that one
out he had to discover well what's this
one how does it work
and that's when he discovered that
there's no explanation for the
extraordinary balance in our atmosphere
between carbon dioxide
you know oxygen nitrogen and and they
look back you know the Vostok ice record
over for two thousand years and so forth
and came out as a hypothesis that there
is actually in its entirety is a living
organism with feedback loops and that
those feedback loops I mean you have
this you know up and down in terms of
ice ages you know and then melts again
and then you know big planet life and
this dis oscillation but underneath that
is actually you have the earth in a
sense it's not controlling but but inner
I mean I it's hard to say because it's
like ice other and there's a Missouri
but I mean the earth is an organism and
now people say that's not true
scientists don't like that and so forth
but he just definitely identified
something that's extraordinary and that
is something I think that has been lost
in the climate conversation is that I
mean when a photon comes down you know
from the Sun that's fusion reactor it's
this little tiny pool of chlorophyll and
goes bouncing around like a billiard
ball until hisses look
little pink swallows that photon like
that and creates energy and grabs some H
from the h2o from the water you know it
spits out oxygen makes a sugar that goes
into protein fats carbohydrates and goes
down to the roots and basically feeds
the soil needs a fun Drive he's a
bacteria you know which makes better
healthy plants healthy so it retains
water I mean you have this extraordinary
thing happened and everything we see
everything we touch everything that's
here tonight was made by light
everything is made by we eat light or
sun-eater's all our food everything even
is artificial it's like it's plastic
whatever where the plastic come from
coal swamps okay or gas or oil and it
came from sunlight and so that
disconnection that this sacred beautiful
thing is happening on earth also
innocence is the description if you will
of how the atmosphere is interacts with
the biosphere right and the cryosphere
right and and it's just a friggin
miracle the more you read about the more
you study more you're in awe like who
could have even been in chlorophyll much
less the whole nine yards the whole
banana it's so beautiful in a handful of
soil there's more bacteria protozoa you
know nematodes mite sanera then there
are in all the human beings that have
ever been on the planet right right in
your hand it is the most complex
ecosystem in the world go out tonight
pick up a handful of soil it's more
complex than the oceans every forest
system you name it it's in your hand
and 90% of what's in that we don't know
what it is we do not know and we have
you know gene sequencing we have the
means to know and we do not know what's
in there and we don't know how it works
and we don't know the interactions and
set you know we take it for granted does
not take it for granted that's what I
was saying earlier about my son just
what you read you know it's ready to
come from in our the people who are
producing our food absolutely honoring
this and regenerating soil because if
they do the food that comes out of it is
extraordinary it's so different then the
food that comes out of basically I
caught Monsanto's soil but it's not soil
its dirt they just saw and made dirt
they killed the life in it and said you
need us because because the soil was
dead and we were saying is you bring it
back to life and you reverse global
warming right where's that Bush see and
he's out here somewhere
Zack wish is here somewhere there he is
there he is beautiful zero
[Applause]
so Zach I've explored this with Zach a
couple times on the podcast soil
regeneration soil depletion the the
pathetic state of of soil today and the
extent to which it's depleting our food
of nutrients and the projections are
pretty dire in terms of how much topsoil
is left if we don't make changes and
revert to these regenerative practices
but what is amazing and encouraging and
and leaves me feeling optimistic is
seeing all of these farmers now
realizing that they can increase their
yields they can increase their profit
margins
when they make these changes and the
sort of scare tactics that this is going
to be a long drawn-out multi-year
process is proving untrue and in fact
the soil is quite adept at regenerating
itself when you do a couple simple
things it is I mean it's fairly
straightforward at the same time I mean
Zach does this wonderful work with
farmers and but it is simple it's
there's a great story in the book called
the to call the reed Warbler by Charles
Massey is absolutely the best book on
regenerative agriculture in the world to
me but it does just started this farmer
and he inherited his father's farm and
was pretty much played out and so he did
what you do with the played out farmers
you put in more inputs more fertilizer
more phosphate you know more potash and
so forth and cranked it up and then it
just went to hell of course and he lost
some more money
and he was about ready to sell it move
back to the city and he want to take a
picture the last picture and he stepped
across his fence to take a picture and
he was standing on the soil diverged you
know it was soft and spongy and those
grass is growing and butterflies and he
he looked at his far
and we're standing uh-huh I'm going oh
my god you know like I haven't done
anything it's not even my land you know
and it's beautiful and for him that was
the door bag and you know years later
because he key line there's so many
techniques to regenerative farming it's
not just basically no-till that's one
cover crops complex cover crops number
two you know and animals is very
important in terms of grazing or some
interaction with the cover crop or the
stubble that's important but what the
key lining is actually having the water
you know you channel it so it's not
going down you know or you know causing
erosion and so you keep the water you
start to recreate the carbon sponge
which is a lot of sponge the so becomes
a sponge again as opposed to a channel
and and then one day he heard a reed
Warbler which he hadn't heard since it
was a child it wasn't any around for a
hundred miles and a reed Warbler grows
on you know goes to weeds in a wetland
and he realized that he turned his
desert back into a wetland and keep
areas and that's why it's such a
beautiful story entitled a book because
it really is about regeneration in what
happens you don't just regenerate soil
you regenerate biodiversity and
pollinators and birds there's a
wonderful story by Isabella tree called
Wilding wonderful book about she and her
husband Charlie Burrell inherited their
family estate 3,500 acres and he did the
same thing at this farmer in Australia
differences basically it was losing
money and so they amped it up better
equipment better pesticides better
controls and bigger fields and they just
almost went bankrupt I mean got worse
and they decided to do something that
actually was very controversial they
tore down all the fences pretty big ring
fence around it
and brought back the ancient animals
that have been on that land of the long
run cattle Tamworth pigs you know and a
type of horse and his name is get ax
more horse okay so these are the these
were the animals that were on that land
you know a thousand 1500 2000 4000 years
ago and they didn't do anything nothing
and they watched it and it was stunning
what happened to that land and the birds
that came back and the trees and the
plants in the water and the peak started
tend to be hippos and diving in the
water and getting fresh water mussels
and the nightingales came back the
turtle doves came back
purple empress butterfly there was they
became a Red List hotspot in other words
for species that were red listed as
going extinct
basically all constituted on this farm
and so there is just there's just the
the prospect of basically of Wilding you
know really Wilding our earth again is
there it's not just about row crops and
regenerative agriculture it's about an
agriculture that actually brings back
life on earth in ways that are so
fantastic and again I just want to say
it is simple in some ways but actually
it is infinitely complex in terms of its
prospects and possibilities and what is
yeah thank you for that and I should
point out
that in addition to the work that that
that Paul is doing in this area Zack has
his farmers footprint nonprofit and
documentary series that goes into this
subject matter in depth and I believe
Ryland from kiss the ground is here as
well yeah Alan here well yeah I was
doing amazing work in this field
encourage you to check out both of them
and more so what is how can we is a
communication like how is a better story
tell how do we catalyze more more of the
farming community to make this - we
don't we let farmers talk to farmers
yeah not right right don't believe us
for sure okay and right it's they don't
really they believe each other and it's
interesting when you talk to the
Vijender farmers in this country I mean
there almost every point of it was a red
state or politically bent that way and
some interesting things come out first
of all the hardest thing for them in
terms of making the transition wasn't
the technique it was their neighbors
because they're so used to having these
glyphosate fields that just are pin neat
you know no weeds you can see the bare
soil and there's the corn coming up or
whatever and there's pride they have a
sense of pride about that like this you
know it looks so beautiful like
Versailles or something you know for
farms and all perfectly groomed and
perfectly green and all sort of stuff
and when you go to regenerative
agriculture you never kill and so
there's always cover and so there's
cover crops that are you know 20 25
different seeds in the seed row I mean
it just looks like chaos looks like a
mess and then it's grazed down and then
it's crimped you know and then you drill
into the crimped straw and plant and
then outcome whatever it is you're
planning and they said the hardest thing
for them was going to the coffee shop in
the morning hmm and their neighbors
going hey Joe what's uh having trouble
out there
and no no you know and but I feel like
you know those smaller rural communities
there they they really do they are
communities and but the bad thing about
communities is that they can also be
conformities which is you don't really
want to stick out yeah you know become a
social pariah you didn't write you do
and I I've heard that again and again
and then but what happened now is you
have these farmers who I don't know of a
farmer
maybe Zach does but who is a resident of
agriculture they didn't hit the wall I
mean in other words they were gonna lose
the farm and when you talk to them they
experience this enormous amount of shame
it's not just stress financial stress
for sure or course but shame is like
fifth generation fourth generation and
everybody had done pretty well and
handed over to this person and they were
gonna fail lose the farm you know lose
the land before closed upon and sell off
the equipment it was just like and their
sense of the shame that they were in
terrorizing was extraordinary and the
when you listen to their stories about
you know turning or turning it around I
mean it is so it is an American tale
because these farmers are really really
good people and they got sold a bill of
goods that worked initially after the
war and for a long time you know you
stick NPK you know into the soil and you
get more there's no question about it
you don't get more better it's like not
really so good but you get more of it
when I started air one in 1966 in Boston
the first farmer we went to was Ted
Widmer in Bloomfield Montana for wheat
and I remember being in his truck and
it's just it's flat and cold there I
don't know how anybody would want to
live there I'm from California but you
know with all due respect eastern
Montana and and he stops on Elkhorn and
he threw in the truck and like stop sue
in the truck and there was other horns
in the back of the pickup
and talked about that he would go and
bones and horns and whatever he could
find for the slaughterhouses and so
forth and grind it up and put on his
soil grind it up put other soil he was
dryland wheat no fertilizer nothing he
didn't convert to organics he never went
off it and his weak weight 63 pounds a
bushel well wheat is 60 pounds that's
their equivalent a bushel weight of 65
and 60 pounds is a bushel his are 63
pounds the wheat we are growing today is
54 55 56 pounds mmm
volumetrically it's it's it's fluff it
doesn't have minerals and ted's across
had more minerals than normally and mmm
so there's this beautiful intelligence
out there in our farm community that has
been suppressed by the constancy of the
propaganda and the BS coming from large
corporations and they have really
convinced people and that's the best and
right way and they've tried to shame the
rest of us who questioned industrial AG
as saying well you know when I started I
want I mean I had these debates at MIT
at Harvard were in Boston and they're
always shaming me because well if
everybody went organic you know all the
children would starve I mean really yeah
and with a straight face you know and so
basically we were inculcated you know
and it's just so farmers are waking up
one by one and what really wakes them up
is farmers like gay brown now who is the
sort of the poster child who wrote a
book about it in North Dakota and you
know he goes around you yeah I think you
can see it at sea and on YouTube you can
see Gabe talking to farmers you know and
and he knows what to say he said like
you know I just got tired of writing my
name on the front of the check he said I
sign it now in the back of the check
he's like yeah it cuts right through you
know
and and they believe him you know
because he's buying more and more land
you know land is degraded and dinner
restoring yeah it's almost like an
escape from indentured servitude that
glide that has been told for generations
that that better living comes through
chemistry and that the yields that you
seek can only be garnered through GMOs
and round up and these pesticides and
fertilizers and then you know enter
stage left Monsanto now bear that
controls all the seeds all the way up to
the diseases that the food is creating I
don't know how that company that merger
passed antitrust muster they're all
wondering in bio this yeah and and and
and the debt structures that are set up
to keep these farmers sort of in line
and and interments and so it's so
encouraging and empowering to see these
individuals figure a way out they're
experimenting
I mean they're really learning about the
different covers cover crops you know
and how they interact and this is this
place selenium just does this obviously
this fixes nitrogen I mean they they're
playing in a way that they never did
like again quoting Gabe and you'll see
it on YouTube he said I used to wake up
every mind it's a it figure out what I
was gonna kill today uh-huh and now I
wake up everywhere anything what am I
gonna make live today that's that's a
fundamental shift in thinking about and
those farmers that they're coming alive
to you know and and because farmers have
been hammered both financially but also
reputationally because of the poison the
glasses say dead zones you know in the
Gulf of Mexico from nitrogen fertilizer
and actually in Iowa and these
communities they're seeing in fifth
generation where you have five
generations alive okay you're seeing
cancers that are so rare I mean there's
thirteen thousand five hundred diseases
you have to learn to be a doctor and
there's this is the thirteen thousand
five hundred
first I mean they have to go to Boston
or someplace to figure out what these
little babies have how in the hell kind
of one-year-old or to Europe get these
kind of rare rare cancers you know well
I mean I mean this is hazy and you know
Iowa in the haze of glyphosate yeah Wow
let's talk about erawan oh yes so you
found it erawan in 66 66 yeah the Erawan
trading company back then and talk to me
about the impetus behind it yeah well at
my motivations were unusual basically I
wanted to read and there was this little
buyers co-op down on Newbury Street in
the basement and nobody wanted to take
care of it and I thought well nobody's
coming in there so I'll take care of it
did $25 on a good day and I was couldn't
be happier I was and I love to read and
still do and one day somebody came into
the store and said how do you know that
your oil is cold pressed and I you know
I had a said cold pressed it was from
Haines there you have it you know some
Haines and then priests in there after
somebody else that came in and said how
do you know your oats or organic and I
said because they come from Mennonites
give me a break you know they're
Mennonite I don't even talk at all you
know I mean because they Corsa and when
they left I mean as a journalist I felt
like you just a bullshitter Hawke and
you know you don't you don't know either
one of those
is crap so I wrote the hain dear mr. hoo
whatever and tell me about your
cold-pressed oils and I got a letter
back beautiful stationery everything and
said well there isn't really any more
cold-pressed oils they're all solvent
extracted what coal press refers to is
that the oils are called processed which
means that once they're solvent
extracted we reduce the temperature to
34 degrees and filter out the steroids
that make the oil cloudy because nobody
likes the cloudy oil and I'm going I was
so pissed off I was so mad and then two
days later the oats come the Mennonites
in Pennsylvania I go ok and I'm grabbing
these oats off the truck and there's a
label so than the Bemis bag and it says
National Oh company Des Moines Iowa and
one after another like six of them so I
call up the Nashville company and say
tell me all about your organic farming
program and it's a nicest woman ever and
she said honey we can you explain that
to me and I said well organic farming
you don't know pesticides of this blah
blah blah gee that sounds very
interesting you know we just buy oats
and roller
and I decided then that I was gonna
replace every single product in that
store from a farmer I knew or had
visited and that was it I was just mad
and that's what I did and the everyone
that's here today is somebody else's
genius and brilliance nothing to do with
me I mean we opened the original story
I'm Beverly Boulevard that yeah but I
mean but the DNA of erawan is that which
is let's get it right and not lie and
and and and not and just be truthful and
be very open and so every label at
erawan had the name of the farm the name
of the farmer where is from the type of
spoils I mean the labels are and said
don't believe us because everybody else
there's a lot people not really being
very truthful about this and so to be
totally transparent it's kind of
whatever Lane does now with clothing
there's yours the factory here's the
workers is what happens and we did it
there with food it's gotta be bizarre
though when you go into an era one now
which is very much a I mean everyone's a
beautiful institution they have amazing
food but it's also very much a see and
be seen thing it's like a you know it's
like a nightclub you know if I was in
the paparazzi I just sit in front of you
know wait okay why chase the stars will
come to you you know I mean could you
have ever like yeah well when we opened
the store in LA on 1970 we did have a
lot right there was a it was the one
place where you could go yeah and did
have a lot and I used to deliver to the
fourth and but so that's true because
actors least some actors there he knew
they had to take good care of them so no
mmm so that's not surprising but
surprising about Iran is it's it's it's
extremely well done and the quality of
the food is amazing
and you know Jasmine my wife is here we
we go there and we I'm it's not because
the name is because it's delicious they
give you a discount huh can you get free
stuff there all right so you're this
amazing entrepreneur this isn't you know
erawan isn't your only thing you've got
once on and Smith and Hawk and garden
supply company you've you know
reinvented yourself as a business person
many times you're this activist you're
this environmentalist you're this
incredible writer it's rare I mean you
find people that Excel and maybe one or
two of these areas but for you to be
able to kind of make your imprint on the
world and in all of these areas is quite
a remarkable thing so talk a little bit
about where and how the writing came to
be the writing came about my mother told
me and I have no memory of this
whatsoever she said when you were four
he said I'm gonna grow up and be a
writer and I was a youngest recorded
case of asthma in San Mateo County
history I had a spent I was 20 years old
the reason I got into natural foods was
because of asthma and and she would just
leave me in bed and then at 3 years old
I learned to read and and books by the
bushel from the library and a little
bookworm contest you know he pasted on
ok
I used to win all the bookworm contests
you know cuz had nothing else to do and
so that writing comes out of reading
really I mean I mean what does a great
musician come from listening to great
music really you know and
great poet comes from reading poetry and
knowing poetry it's all the same in that
sense all those kind of professions and
so but I think it also came from being
an outsider you know I mean I came from
a really it wasn't safe to be in my
house as a child hmm it was unsafe and
so I would spend as much time as
possible outside and I felt safe there
always this matter rain or lightning or
floods or even far as far I was up and
and I always felt safe like I was held
in hands you know I mean mother nature
really was a mother for me you know but
the thing about being outside is it's
different than inside in many many ways
but one is that if you stay inside if
you're a child you can master the inside
in an hour - here's the bathroom here's
a refrigerator his TV or whatever he was
a light switch I mean there's not much
to master and understand in the house
outside you can spend 10 lifetimes and
not know really what everything is and
the sounds and how it works and what
crawls away and so it just fed this
insatiable curiosity yeah that's I mean
curiosity is the word that comes to mind
and yeah if you could you can be outside
if you're not a curious person all of
that will elude you right so you're you
have this predisposition to curiosity
that's almost right you know and so
naturally I did that I mastered
something is actually I would put it in
differently which is I got very curious
about something and then I took it on to
do it even though I didn't know how to
do it or even writing I actually learned
by writing other words I I have some
insight I think I think it might be I
might think this is a better way of
looking at it and we've never looked at
it this way or should we talk about
College of Commerce you know
and the Blessed unrest but but it really
comes from wanting to know as opposed
knowing it's not that I know me because
I don't know and I feel really
comfortable in not knowing so I felt
comfortable in Erewhon I mean I remember
a Taiwan them like sixth or seventh year
and we were a favorite target or subject
for Harvard Business School to people
getting their you know MBA and they're
do the thesis on mmm case study oh yeah
oh yeah six of them and just crossed the
river close by you know all that sort of
stuff and I remember one guy came in
once and I used to bicycle with him a
lot he was on the Olympic team and the
Harvard bicycle Burmese bike a lot on
the concrete and name is Graham and he
said it was like ten the morning he said
you know I have to got to talk to you I
talked to you a part of me was at
OpenOffice you know he said I can't talk
to you here so what do you wanna do so
was go down to the No Name bar which is
in South Boston I said 10 a.m. you know
come on said what you'll need a drink
and you know so we went down there and
he said I I hate to tell you this but
basically you're out of business I said
really
so how do you know that and he Pauli's
papers he says you have negative net
worth and you know negative working
capital and this that all these terms
and my balance sheet missing that and I
was lucky and I mean he said doesn't
that bother you I said not really
he said why said cuz I don't know what
you're talking about
I don't know much negative working
capital areas not really didn't like oh
well okay you know it's interesting and
he said we should just kind of check in
and you know pay people off because the
government's really gonna hammer you if
you don't do that first you know you
know and then closed doors anyway I said
what you think I should do he said well
he said was your knowledge that that is
a finance he you probably get a job at
the US government is good it was like it
was a lame joke at the time but anyway
it went on been through an era once or
maybe some of you and but it was so
interesting because you know I mean when
I was drafted you know the same question
I mean and so earlier and when I was
drafted I got a hundred it's not really
an intelligence test this is it's the
stupidity test you'd have to be stupid
not to pass the Testament and but I had
asthma my life my husband and it's
always I was you know 4f and all that
sort of stuff and I was taken to our
counselors during LBJ in the Great
Society and she had up my high school
record it's got record and she's like
looking at it like this like that and
she's saying high school wasn't your
finest hour was it I said no and she
said I don't really see a career path
for you
she was a career counselor in aha
I think she's right actually and yeah
and she said tell me did you just not
care do you do your homework in the dark
no she said do you come from a family of
artists so I might say this or do you do
your homework of the dart right and I
took real umbrage at that first part
because I was surrounded by artists my
father and his friends were artists and
you know and I said well what do you
suggest I do she said I think you should
get a job with the post office they take
anyone there's twice in my life opposed
so going back to mastery I never felt
like a master I felt like a learner and
I just felt like we're here to learn
both self and other in place right yeah
somebody who has whose muses curiosity
and always has followed their curiosity
and that has led you on this circuitous
path that we I guess we can call a
career sometimes at my peril right
others yes our time is short we have to
wrap this up soon here but before we do
that I wanted to give you a little bit
of an opportunity to talk about this new
book that you have coming out as a
sequel to drawdown can you talk about
that a little bit yeah regeneration is
the name of the book to the working
subtitle is ending the climate crisis in
one generation
it doesn't mean ending it in finality it
means pushing out the horizon that is
the the sense of we only have you know
11 more years ago and otherwise we're
gonna go right over the cliff and so
it's undertaking enough activity in
actions in such a way that when we get
to whether it's 2025 or 2030 we actually
see that we still have a horizon that is
durable and we've undertaken enough
things that make us feel like we know
what we're doing that it's working and
it's really based on as I said turning
around you know to the mothership really
and looking at the scope and breadth of
what is possible if we start to
in alignment with nature and it doesn't
mean abandoning our cities in fact there
is a section on city section on food
section on energy but actually talks
about making cities like forests there
were cities that are sinks instead of
sources the idea that we can reduce
energy be a LEED Gold that's great but
why not
think big there isn't a town a company
named trial for energy it's a fusion
company and I love it because their
purpose is to make star light on earth
cause that's what fusion is star light
the Sun is a star and I feel like we
need unreasonable goals you know
drawdown in a sense it shouldn't be
violently that's a reasonable goal but
it was at the time and regeneration is
really about that and triumph of energy
was an unreasonable goal and
unreasonable goals or forcing functions
like in calculus they forced a different
outcome when JFK announced that man put
a person on the moon within a decade
that was the goal thirty thousand
different technologies came out of that
that would not have been invented
necessarily then or at all had they not
actually had this forcing function or
putting a human being on the moon sounds
simple it was not simple and I feel like
drawdown was all peer-reviewed science
and you know modeled and very in the
sense it's very bounded by science and
by peer review and by economic robust
data ie and so forth he was reflection
back to the world what it knows and what
it's doing where regeneration is about
is all also about science but it's not
peer-reviewed we don't have time to peer
review the science its emerging and
growing and it's just extraordinary
what's happening underneath this
headlines you know around the world and
we don't hear that what we hear is the
headlines and the media and the
back-and-forth and the fighting and we
get books uninhabitable earth you know
and the end of ice you know
I don't know about you but I don't read
those at night I mean there's our
bedtime stories and it's not that the
science that David Wells Wallace basing
it on is not valid it's just that it's
not helpful anymore to know that and so
I want to create a book that does that
but I also want to show which I spoke up
early or that it's really about meeting
current human needs that it is just so
much about you know mountains and it's
about migrants you know both it's about
for us but it's about favelas as well
you know that actually this other ring
of the world you know seeing everything
as separate is the cause of global
warming it's the cause there are
disconnection it is the disconnection
and so regeneration is very much about
that my wife bless her said Paul if you
don't have what you do in this book I'm
leaving you so yeah yeah and said like
people say well what can I do to exactly
when you're like I can't tell you what
to do what kind of person do you want to
be this is the journey that you have to
go on I know I used to say that leaves
you at square one now I got to shut that
up and go say this is what you can do
all right
and and on every level of agency you
know whether an individual is city
manager of buildings and grounds you run
a company and it's very clear and it has
the seventh section it's called social
which is about the path communication
mobilization complex adaptive systems it
talks about how we naturally organize
ourselves and it proposes the inter
organizational panel on climate
solutions the IP C s not the CC and it
says is anytime three or four or five
people can get together at a church
basement at school and a company city
council whatever
that's the IPC s and the way we solve
this get together talk rich where do you
know what you're doing at your house
what is what we're doing this one we
found out this really works you know so
and so yeah I
Zach Busch will bring him in I mean
that's what people do that's a community
and the way we're gonna solve this is to
be community around this in a way that's
effective because the only ones gonna
happen is in place not from Paris not
from Chile and not from New York
certainly god bless everybody who's
doing that meeting it's I'm not speaking
against I I'm just speaking towards this
fact that the way we're going to do it
is to come together in ways that
actually you know honor our
relationships and in our community and
our sense of who we want to be right now
who do we want to be you know and so
that's what regeneration is about
there's more to it but then essentially
yeah bringing it around the community
yeah
thank you Paul Hawken
[Music]
[Applause]
you're a beautiful human I salute you so
much respect for the work that you do
and and what you're putting out into the
world your work is important and thank
you so much for sharing rich thank you
for everything and thank you to all of
you for coming out tonight I appreciate
you I love you what a fantastic evening
so thank you so much thank you thank you
for coming
[Applause]
[Music]